زياره الرئيس الاوكراني للولايات المتحده
يصفها داعياف بالتاريخيه وتصفها موسكو
بالتصعيد الواضح زياره حملت في طياتها
مؤشرات عده
[موسيقى]
العسكريين مع بوتين اطلق خلاله استراتيجيه
بلاده العسكريه
الجديده الى اوكرانيا
بالمواجهه العسكريه الغربيه غير المباشره
مستبعدا بذلك اي فرصه لمحادثات السلام
[موسيقى]
زياره الاسكيجات بعد ايام من زياره
الروسيه اقلقت كيف والغرب حاطه فيها بوتين
ريحانه في بيلاروسيا وارسله من خلالها
رسائل واتفاقات عده ترسم ملامح الجبهه
الشرقيه اخترت بيلاروسيا
العسكري واستعدادها للحرب ضد اي تحديث
الجديده
قرابه وعشره اشهر منذ بدا الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا بدا الطرفان بتحسين
القدراتهم العسكريه شيئا فشيئا وابقى
تطلبه تغيرات ارض المعركه روسيا زادت من
قدراتها العسكريه
والصواريخ بعيده المدى